[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants nounours est content
ce soir
[Musique]
car je vais voir mes amis mon échelle et
hop là
[Musique]
bravo cornichon mais comment tu es seul
oui dada est allé chercher Pépita oh
tiens les voilà qui reviennent
quel cours se pour retrouver cette
Pépita
du miel des fleurs
[Musique]
regardez un lapin
il s'appelle Jeannot je l'ai trouvé dans
la clairière il courait vite alors j'ai
jeté mon châle dessus et je l'ai pris
salut Jeannot tu as de belles oreilles
un joli petit nez j'apporte quelque
chose pour Jeannot Lapin
[Musique]
si vous voulez mon avis vous vous
occupez beaucoup trop de lui dans la
forêt il vivait seul et se débrouiller
très bien il avait une maman lapin dans
la forêt je suis de la vie de Dada vous
devez lui laisser à boire et à manger
sur la table et il fera ce qu'il a envie
de faire moi je suis sûr qu'il a envie
de dormir
à cette heure-ci les lapins dorment dans
la forêt tu as raison
là on voit jamais la
[Musique]
cornichon tu l'empêcheras de dormir
bonne nuit nounou bonne nuit mes amis
[Musique]
ne ronfle pas trop les camarades
pas trop oh pas trop Pépita attrapé un
joli petit lapin c'est vrai oui ce qu'il
est mignon elle a porté chez cornichon
mais demain je lui dirai qu'il faut le
remettre en liberté c'est plus gentil
n'est-ce pas oui nounours il sera plus
heureux en liberté allons en route bonne
nuit les enfants aux routes faites de
beaux rêves
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]